[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 culture une émission pour
vous présenter les initiatives
culturelles dans les yvelines
au sommaire aujourd'hui les
établissements culturels s'organise pour
faire vivre leurs projets de plus en
plus d'exposition visible de l'extérieur
prennent place à travers les vitrines ou
directement hors les murs l'exemple avec
la barbacane le théâtre de fontenay le
fleury a mis en place une exposition jeu
cette dernière est visible à travers la
vitrine du reste au théâtre le principe
représenter des mises en scène des
erreurs se sont glissées qu'il faudra
les retrouver enfin situé à plaisir le
théâtre eurydice et un esat qui
accompagne les personnes en situation de
handicap dans leur projet professionnel
objectif l'inclusion par la culture nous
sommes allés à leur rencontre et je vous
le disais en titre derrière les vitres
de la barbacane à berne l'exposition
corpus corus est à découvrir jusqu'au 6
mars
elle retrace les oeuvres chorégraphiques
d'olivier dubois danseur et chorégraphe
de renom présentation de l'exposition
par célia guettent son gorille garde et
ne pouvant pas accueillir du public la
barbacane s'est organisée pour rendre la
culture accessible à tous l'exposition
corpus corus crée autour de l'univers du
danseur et chorégraphe olivier dubois
est visible uniquement depuis
l'extérieur
l'idée est vraiment de plonger dans le
corps de voir des images des gens en
mouvement parce que dans ces périodes
compliquées ça nous manque
nous sommes très contents de présenter
cette exposition
[Musique]
l'exposition se compose de huit photos
présentant différentes pièces d'olivier
dubois
il ya également un reportage sur
l'univers de ce chorégraphe et quelques
planches viennent s'ajouter à la
collection où l'on découvre des
notations de chorégraphie les vitres de
la du bâtiment ça un autre encore écran
mais ça permet voilà peut-être plus dans
le réel et d'aller aussi chercher des
gens qui n'ont pas fait le choix de voir
cette exposition et qui la découvre et
qui peuvent être interpellés interloqué
curieux normalement le chorégraphe était
attendu à la barbacane le 6 mars
mais la crise sanitaire oblige son
report sur la saison 2022 2023
d'ailleurs l'une des photos représentent
un de ses spectacles nommé tragédie dans
ce spectacle là le rapport au corps est
très important et il était question de
dépasser la question du corps de
l'interprète pour vraiment voir le
mouvement est donc on est dans un
spectacle très fort très percutant
l'exposition est à voir tous les jours
jusqu'au 6 mars prochain une exposition
urbaine
hors les murs c'est ce qu'a organisé la
ville de maurepas en partenariat avec le
photographe jean-pierre evrard la ville
s'est adapté aux mesures sanitaires en
vigueur vingt portraits sont
actuellement visibles et exposé dans le
centre ville
un avant goût du prochain salon mort
parts eléonore sinoquet est allé à
découvrir l'exposition regards des mots
repartent prend l'air à la crise
sanitaire a obligé la ville de mort par
penser autrement son espace culturel
c'est donc une exposition hors les murs
qui prend place dans la ville
il ya un énorme besoin de relations
sociales de culture aujourd'hui bon bah
nous sommes allés vers
elle est morte aziez en espérant qu'il
revienne vers nous très vite au mot
repartent évidemment c'est le mort nazi
un jean-pierre evrard qui a été choisie
par la commune pour être l'invité
d'honneur
il présente plusieurs portraits sur le
thème de la fête du vaudou est des
photos qui lui viennent de ses nombreux
voyages en afrique une fête célébrée
chaque année le 10 janvier au bénin la
fête du vaudou est beaucoup plus récente
c'était un hommage en toutes ces
personnes qui ont disparu qui ont
souffert dans la traite des esclaves
donc c'est une connaissance de ce
festival est donc je suis allée une
première année puis jardin deuxième
n'est que troisième année une quatrième
année et donc ça représente amis et de
photos à peu près parmi elles 20 photos
ont été sélectionnées pour l'exposition
mort par tu prends l'air
pour jean-pierre evrard ces photos
relève d'un travail d'artisan l'homme
qui est devant dans son laboratoire d'un
sur jambes renoir est qui qui
travaillent ceux qui manipulent ces
photos on s'en fout bulls l'homme
étudiants-athlètes un petit peu moins la
machine une exposition en libre accès
organisée au coeur de la ville un
endroit stratégique pour que le maximum
de personnes puissent s'y arrêter voilà
un mot repas est quand même une ville
dite dortoir à l'origine avec quelques
centres on a vraiment pris le
centre-ville mort par te prend l'air est
un avant-goût de la 36e édition du salon
mort parts qui devrait prendre place le
13 mars pour l'occasion de nouvelles
oeuvres seront exposées au centre albert
camus depuis le 13 février une
exposition jeu est visible depuis la
terrasse de la crêperie le reste au
théâtre juste à côté du théâtre et
cinéma de fontenay le fleury celi agathe
saint gobain soirée techno dont soir
alors expliquez nous un peu comment on
peut jouer et bien déjà le décor se
compose de neuf mannequin avec des
costumes de théâtre dans cette scène
romantique d'un repas pour la saint
valentin
vingt-et-une erreur plus ou moins facile
de se sont glissés bien sûr pour que
toute la famille puisse jouer par
exemple un téléphone portable dans une
main d'un personnage ou une assiette
retourné sur une table dressée
ensuite vous trouverez sur le site
internet le formulaire réponse jeu pour
noter toutes les coquilles que vous
aurez trouvé
le but de cette exposition est bien sûr
de continuer à proposer des projets
culturels
alors pour nous c'est une manière de
montrer que tu as très bien fermer une
manière de montrer qu'on est vivant
parce que ce que les gens savent pas
c'est qu'on est quand même autorisé à
vous savez mettre en scène a travaillé à
répéter le spectacle est donc on était
triste de deux blessés en de laisser
croire aux gens que le théâtre était
mort en fait dit qu'on était touchant
parce qu'on avait déserté donc non je
dis moi la patère cette initiative est
donc que peut-on gagner c'est bien bien
dix lots sont à gagner
ce seront 10 gagnants qui auront
retrouvé le plus grand nombre de bonnes
réponses en cas d'égalité à un tirage au
sort sera effectué et ce sont des lots
très différent écouter on faire une
séance nous d'esthétique et dacourt fait
sans toutefois plus jeune a confirmé
repas et la conférence est vraiment
sympa franche maison jouets jeux que
nous ne resterons faisait pas ça pour
l'argent puisque en plus c'est gratuit
tout ça donc on a fait ça pour dynamiser
un peu me montrer qu'être vivant que la
ville soit diverti malgré tout
l'explosion se déroule jusqu'au 31 mars
et petite info un justin le théâtre de
fontenay est aussi un cinéma
il propose donc des diffusions gratuites
en ligne chaque semaine de spectacles
comme la fleur au fusil par exemple et
si diffusion sont suivies seulement le
dimanche après midi d'un échange avec
les acteurs du spectacle
merci célia agathe congo d'avoir été
avec nous on vous retrouve bien
évidemment vendredi pour le 7-8 week end
oui bien sûr situé à plaisir le théâtre
eurydice et un esat qui accompagne les
personnes en situation de handicap dans
leur projet professionnel
objectif l'inclusion par la culture nous
sommes allés à leur rencontre regardée
un théâtre qui fonctionne grâce à des
personnes en situation de handicap
objectif du théâtre eurydice sauvegarde
l'inclusion par la culture cv lettre de
motivation tous sont passés par un
entretien d'embauché
il ya un vrai travail de qualité ont
fait pas de l'occupationnel en esat du
tout on est là pour faire un travail de
qualité entre avec des clients on a des
délais à respecter une qualité à
produire tous les clients qui
travaillent avec nous son
content en tout cas est satisfait de là
quelqu'un de notre travail au programme
ateliers de confection de costumes
construction de décors régie son et
lumière ou encore troupe de comédiens
les a trop coupe des travailleurs en
situation de handicap dans le domaine du
spectacle vivant
ils sont accompagnés par des
professionnels quand ils arrivent au
mont à ce qu'on appelle un projet adapté
personnalisés donc vraiment c'est un
projet professionnel
ils nous disent ce qu'ils ont envie de
faire et nombre est là pour les
accompagner on n'est pas là pour leur
dire si c'est réalisable pas réalisable
voilà c'est eux c'est leur projet on va
faire au mieux pour les accompagner là
dedans donc si leur objectif c'est de
travailler en milieu ordinaire aides à
l'hectare d'affaires de la restauration
ben voilà on va essayer de travailler
avec petit à petit il est 9h rovny qui
arrive à les ath
le jeune comédien et malvoyants due à
une déficience visuelle de naissance il
fait partie de l'atelier théâtre depuis
quatre ans en avril 2016 il a passé un
casting sur cinq jours pour intégrer la
structure
ce matin on a commencé les exercices
physiques
voilà un diner et après on a enchaîné
chacun travaille sur le texte moi je
travaille sur le mien à la ont répété
avec mon partenaire le feu par exemple à
aucun prix je ne me promènerai dans une
forêt qui flambent
mais moi je sais pourquoi pour moi pour
les textes les pièces de théâtre il faut
soit agrandi son blue dragon dur pour
moi peau qu'elle d'aliens normalement
rovny qu'à travailler au conservatoire
de versailles pendant trois ans
parallèle de son accompagnement à les at
il souhaiterait poursuivre dans la voie
du spectacle vivant
son but être comédien pourtant pas
évident de trouver une place
bah faut qu'elle soit comme ça il a été
acteur de casting accepte aussi des
personnes en situation d'handicap aussi
parce que c'est difficile de trouver des
personnes qui a envie de travailler avec
des comédiens pour leurs 57 travailleurs
en situation de handicap travail au
théâtre a dit ça il faut choisir
encore quelques jours pour contribuer à
la campagne de financement participatif
lancé par l'association les a
du musée de la toile de jouy
l'association cherche à récupérer un
dessin du peintre louis léopold boily il
représente en fait le créateur de la
toile de jouy christophe philippe
oberkampf ainsi que sa famille
l'objectif c'est de récolter 25 mille
euros pour pouvoir acquérir à cette
oeuvre écoutiez écouter etienne mallet
président de l'association là il ya une
occasion à saisir et à ne pas laisser
s'échapper parce que ce dessin est un
dessin très connue très connu et en plus
ce qui concerne directement donc le
fondateur de la toile de jouy et donc
celle assez naturel qu on essaye de
trouver les moyens financiers pour
pouvoir l'acquérir les une galerie
privée et elle est on a réussi à obtenir
de cette galerie que plutôt qu'il qu'ils
la mettent en vente et qu'elles
partiront saison qui nous donne le temps
de pouvoir réunir les sommes nécessaires
pour pouvoir l'acquérir en faveur du
musée a lancé une campagne via une
plateforme de de financement
participatif comme on dit qui s'appelle
d'artagnan qui est une grande plateforme
connue en france la campagne de
financement participatif est ouverte
jusqu'au 5 mars près de 13000 euros ont
déjà pu être récoltés pour contribuer au
projet rendez vous sur la plateforme
d'artagnan point fr rubrique musée et
c'est la fin de ce statut de culture
merci de nous avoir suivis rendez vous
la semaine prochaine même jour même
heure très bonne soirée sur tv 78 et
d'ici là portez vous bien
[Musique]